hey everyone this is Lucy and in this
video we're going to be building one of
my favorite AWS Cloud projects this is a
very simple AWS project for absolute
beginners and only takes around 15
minutes to build a lot of you really
enjoyed my recent video on the top AWS
projects for beginners and wanted to
know what other projects you can build
on AWS so here's what I'm thinking and
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below I want to start a monthly
build with me Series where every month I
walk you through step by step how to
build an AWS Cloud project I want to
make sure these projects are very simple
and beginner friendly so that it doesn't
take you days and weeks to complete in
fact by the end of each video If you
decide to follow along you want to build
a cool Cloud project that combines a few
AWS Services if you like the idea
comment below with the phrase let's
build together just so I know whether I
should make more videos like this so for
today's project we'll be launching a
static website using two AWS Services
Amazon S3 and Amazon route 53. we'll
start off by creating a custom domain
name using Route 53 then we'll use an
Amazon S3 bucket to host a sample
website and finally we'll enable static
website hosting connected to the domain
name and view our website okay let's
jump straight into it and open up the
AWS console by the way I'd highly
recommend you follow along in real time
and pause the video when you need so the
first step is to head to the Amazon
Route 53 dashboard we're going to start
off by purchasing a domain name for
example if I click on registered domains
you can see here that I've already
registered tequiluci.click let me show
you how you can register your own domain
name if you click on register domain you
can type in a domain name you'd like for
example Lucy project
dot click and the reason I'm choosing
dot click is because it's the cheapest
one I can find check if it's available
and add it to your card
and fill in your contact details after I
type in my details the final stage is to
accept the terms and conditions when
you're on this page make sure you click
disable when asked if you want to
automatically renew your domain that way
you won't be charged after one year once
your domain expires accept the terms and
conditions and complete order
okay so hero says that the domain
registration might take up to three days
to complete but usually it only takes
around 10 minutes for me so while we're
waiting for the domain registration to
be completed I'd like to take a moment
to tell you about today's video sponsor
brilliant one of the best ways to
understand technical Concepts is by
going back to the fundamentals brilliant
is a learning platform with Hands-On
courses in maths science and computer
science the lessons are very interactive
and you'll be guided through fun
problems that come with detailed
Solutions if you're someone looking to
start your career in the cloud industry
and want to improve your programming
skills you can check out their
programming with python course you can
get started with brilliant for free by
heading to brilliant.org forward slash
Tech with Lucy and the first 200 people
will also get 20 off their annual
membership now let's get back to the
video so what a domain has been
registered you can then head to the next
step and the next step is to go to the
Amazon S3 page and create a bucket
so this bucket will be used to host our
website so once you click on create
bucket type in the domain name that you
registered Tech with Lucy dot click
so for this to work make sure you use
the same name as a domain you registered
for the region you can select a region
that is closest to where you live in
order to make sure that you can reduce
latency so in my case I live in Sydney
so I'm going to select the AP Southeast
2 region scroll down to the bottom and
uncheck this block Public Access this is
to make sure that the users will have
access to your bucket and make sure it's
publicly accessible to others on the
internet acknowledge this warning
and keep all the other settings as
default so once the bucket has been
created you can see here there's
tequiluci.click as a bucket click into
your own bucket
and select upload so what we're going to
do is we're going to upload our website
and for this demo I've decided to keep
it very simple and just have a single
page as the website so I'm going to
upload the contents on my website which
is this index.html file select upload
and the page has been uploaded what
we're going to do is make sure that this
bucket is enabled for static website
hosting and making sure that it has the
right permissions for users to access it
so if you click on properties
scroll down all the way to the bottom to
static website hosting
you can see by default it's disabled but
what we're going to do is enable it and
at the index document section type in
the index document in my case index.html
click save changes
and another thing we need to do is on
permissions we need to attach a bucket
policy so click edit and put in a bucket
policy I'll provide this bucket policy
in the details below so you can copy and
paste this in
here you can see that there is the
bucket name but you would have to put in
your own bucket name
so I'm going to type in
heck with Lucy dot click so this policy
is only a template so you'll need to
provide your own bucket name in order
for this policy to work so click save
changes
and we've now configured the bucket to
have the sample website publicly
accessible for viewers so once we go
into this website
if you click on open you'll see the
welcome message and you see you know
welcome to my website now hosted on
Amazon S3 so what you've done at this
point is you hosted the website on
Amazon S3 but as you can see here on the
URL it's not your custom URL this is a
Amazon provided URL
so what we have to do now is redirect
Tech with lucy.click to this S3 bucket
in order to do this we will have to go
back to route 53. if you go back to
Route 53 and click on the hosted Zone
at this point when we click on our
domain name we'll need to add an
additional record and this record is to
make sure that the bucket will be
connected to the Route 53 domain name so
click on create record choose the simple
routing policy click next
and now we're going to Define a simple
record so for the value as I mentioned
the endpoint would have to be the S3
bucket so you can type in Alias to S3
website endpoint
choose the region where you hosted your
bucket in my case the AP Southeast 2
region
and then select the S3 endpoint and you
can see it's already provided for me
here
click this and then for the evaluate
Target Health this is something for the
demo we'll just select no and then
create the record by clicking Define
simple record
and yep just double confirm here create
records
it does take up to a few minutes to
propagate the changes so you can see
take with lucy.click is the custom
domain and you can see that it's
pointing to the S3 bucket and showing
the same message so welcome to our
website now hosted on Amazon S3 in
summary what we did was we created a
nursery bucket uploaded our website
content and connected it to a custom
domain name so that when users type in
your domain name into the browser they
can now view the website alright so this
brings us to the end of this video
please give it a like if you enjoyed it
and I'll see you soon bye for now